my artist of my life is Beyonce miss
album for me the lemonade album was just
so monumental Beyonce
ever since that moment at the 2017
Grammys we thought a Beyonce and Adele
collab was for sure coming our way
and we almost did well we thought we had
it all I would try to cheer on for like
any kind of secrets but I know that that
was one republic's frontman Ryan Tedder
teasing his band's upcoming album during
an interview with z100 at the global
citizen festival over the weekend
promising the world the biggest song
possibly of all time people don't know
is it on the radio like 95% of songs you
hear are Ryan Tedder songs yeah Ryan's
written a lot of big songs including
ones for Adele and Beyonce but fast
forward to Monday when the OneRepublic
singer revealed that he was joking the
entire time in an epic IG story's post
first he shared three of my favorite
things
absurdity kidding joking alongside their
dictionary definition then he posted his
version of the conversation about
Beyonce and Adele that goes like this
journalist any cool collaborations on
the next one Republic album me utilizing
sarcasm kidding and a joke
simultaneously yeah we have one song
featuring Beyonce Adele and Chris Martin
but I don't want to talk about it or
give too much away
cheddar also shared screenshots of the
headlines of comment generated with the
caption come on people
[Music]
he ended the post writing all that said
wouldn't that be a fire collab I'd
stream it so would we Ryan so would we